the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
we're continuing this you know
continuing to put pressure on them to
strangle them to pummel them with
sanctions
applying pressure congresswoman susie
lee on measures the u.s is taking to
stop russia's invasion of ukraine
i've been in north las vegas since 1964.
i am just in touch with the community i
understand the needs and the wants and i
communicate with my constituents
aiming to be the next mayor of north las
vegas councilman pamela goins-brown
talks about affordable housing and
diversity
yes we do have a problem yes yes it is
very concerning
a shortage of state police causing
dangerous situations on our highways the
eight news now i-team tells us why
troopers are leaving
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler we're
going to start with russia's invasion of
ukraine this week more harsh words from
president joe biden for russian
president vladimir putin mr biden called
putin mr biden called putin rather a war
criminal and a murderous dictator now
two americans are among the thousands
who have been killed in the conflict
president biden is also warning mr putin
there will be consequences for any war
crimes committed
putin's brutality and what he's doing
and his troops are doing ukraine is just
inhumane
meanwhile the president has detailed 800
million dollars in new military
assistance to ukraine that includes
anti-aircraft systems small arms and
specialized drones the white house has
opposed though
no fly zone over ukraine officials
believe that would only accelerate the
conflict president biden will explore
more sanctions in the future the
question is though are those sanctions
enough more than 3 million refugees have
already left ukraine we spoke with
democratic representative susie lee from
here in southern nevada we talked about
the ukraine situation we spoke not long
after president zielinski from ukraine
gave an impassioned speech to congress
you heard the president
really plea for no-fly zones for you
know the planes from poland
i'm not sure how much of that you can
you can address but when you talk about
getting more done
um
is it enough
and what else would you like to do yeah
listen i you know when you talk about a
no-fly zone i mean in order to have a
no-fly zone you have to
patrol it and implement the no-fly zone
which would require us to shoot down
russian jets which would require the
united states to send our men and women
to ukraine and potentially get shot down
themselves
uh you know we need to make clear we do
not want to stumble into world war iii
but we can do everything at our
fingertips and at our disposal obviously
that has an impact here at home uh you
know as well as i do that the gas prices
in uh southern nevada right now are
i think it's the second highest in the
country maybe third behind california
and hawaii
what do you tell your constituents that
are going to their the gas station in
your district and are paying
five sometimes six dollars a gallon to
fill up their cars
yeah i mean you know uh right now the
average price of gas in nevada is over
five dollars a gallon and it obviously
has an impact on everyone's pocketbook
uh you know filling up your gas tank
going to and from work
you know many families not taking trips
because of the price of gas and so it's
certainly something that we in congress
are paying a heck of a lot of attention
to
uh i will say that you know we have seen
uh the price of crude oil uh go down a
30
from the same price from this time a
month ago but you're still continuing to
see
uh prices go up at the gas pump which is
why i joined my colleagues in signing a
letter to the administration to
investigate and hold hearings on uh this
price gouging being done by
our oil companies and we already saw
yesterday the senate started hearings
and we're going to start those hearings
here in the house of representatives
for the full interview with
congresswoman lee just head to eight
newsnow dot com
all right let's talk about the look
ahead to the 2022 election season more
candidates are now finalizing their
campaigns and actually submitting their
names officially for the race nevada
senator catherine cortez masto put in
the paperwork for her re-election up in
carson city this week former attorney
general adam laxalt and wounded warrior
sam brown are the two favorites for the
republican nomination to run against her
a change of heart for las vegas city
councilwoman michelle fiore on twitter
she abandoned her bid for governor
instead fiore says she's going to run
for state treasurer fiori first entered
the gubernatorial race in october
fiori dropping out sort of thins out a
busy republican gubernatorial primary
new polling as you see on your screen
there shows clark county sheriff joe
lombardo with a slim lead the poll comes
from the company public policy on behalf
of democrats former senator dean heller
and north las vegas mayor john lee are
close behind but a quarter of voters who
were polled say they're not sure who
they'd vote for
after several questions aimed at
questioning lombardo's conservative
credentials
support tapered off in that poll
there is one surprise entry in the
governor's race now former clark county
commissioner tom collins the only
democrat who has filed to run against
incumbent governor steve sisolak in the
primary collins has been criticizing
governor sissel act nearly every day on
twitter
so so far there are five candidates now
running for north las vegas mayor and
here are the candidates so far nevada
assemblywoman pat spearman who is also a
veteran and a pastor pamela goings-brown
is running she's been on the north las
vegas city council since 2011 and has
served as mayor pro temper twice
nathan adkins is a businessman who
served in the military and robert taylor
owns the fatamal barbershop franchise
franchise and host of other stores in
the city laura perkins is a university
regent and former planning commissioner
and jesse addison who had a career in
the military and in law enforcement all
six candidates for mayor in north las
vegas are black
current city councilman pamela
goins-brown hopes to make history and be
north las vegas first black mayor she's
a democrat although the race for city
elections is technically nonpartisan
goings-brown was first elected back in
2011 some of her opponents say term
limits should keep her from becoming
mayor we asked goings-brown to respond
i think my opponents know that i would
make the best mayor candidate so
they are resorting to
a legal stunt and so i have confirmed
with multiple experts on these issues
and i don't have any problem with term
limits you were sort of leading
fundraising right now
what do you think sets you apart from
the other
other candidates who are running right
now i'm on the ground daily i'm in the
community i know this community like
i've been in north las vegas since 1964.
i am just in touch with the community i
understand the needs and the wants and i
communicate with my constituents often
and i consider myself a problem solver
whether i'm fixing a pothole or working
on bringing our city back from financial
ruins i'm pretty versed in all of those
things north las vegas is a diverse
community obviously and you yourself and
others who are running for mayor
um it would be the first
african-american black person to be
mayor of the city
in terms of representing the community
why is do you believe it is important to
to have someone in that position
to be able to speak to the community a
little better
i just think i can relate to the
community that's been my home since we
moved here in 1964 and i know north las
vegas inside and out and right now we
are the one of the largest minority
majority cities and so it's important
that we keep our diversity strong and we
celebrate our cultural differences and
so that involves people of all
ethnicities and all backgrounds what is
something that you are seeing at city
council on a regular basis that
needs to be addressed yes people need
places to live people need places to
work but is there is a particular issue
that
isn't getting addressed by the current
administration that you and your
administration would be able to do
right now we have a council that's very
cohesive and we we work very very great
together and our long-term goal is just
redevelopment in some of our mature
neighborhoods and that will be
our downtown area and i think that's our
challenge that we are working on
currently and it's just ink on the paper
right now and so you're going to see a
north las vegas downtown area like no
other your background is an education
obviously you were in the schools public
schools for what 30 uh 35 years
who's counting 35 years there have been
some challenges with clark county school
district recently we've been asking a
lot of candidates about resurrecting the
idea of splitting up clark county school
district north las vegas and you in
particular have done some interesting
and innovative things with schools
during the pandemic and afterwards
what would you do as mayor to try and
facilitate that to try and improve
education to try and get the kids the
the schooling they need we have launched
an educational advocacy advocacy
committee and they had their first
meeting last week and they were just
seated just to go over the nuts and
bolts about how to conduct a public
meeting but the goal of that committee
is to what i call offer wrap-around
services to our north las vegas schools
we feel that north las vegas has been
disproportionately represented as far as
staffing and curriculum issue and you
know access to quality education in high
quality seats and so this committee will
be able to
reach out to those schools and see what
can we do to assist you to bring in
quality programming
things that maybe clark county school
district know no fault of theirs that
may not be able to provide so we can be
that resource or you know that backdoor
way to try to get resources to our north
las vegas schools
do you think clark county school
district should be broken up
at this time after
putting together a micro school in three
weeks our southern nevada urban micro
academy and what it takes to put that
together i don't want to tackle that
just yet
it's a lot it's very intense there's a
lot of moving parts
and we will try and speak with the other
candidates for north las vegas mayor
here on politics now as the campaign
goes on
nia county commissioners have
unanimously voted to get rid of
electronic voting machines but there's a
snag the county wants to get rid of the
dominion voting machines they've been
the focus of conspiracy theories about
the 2020 election being stolen
instead nye county the commissioners
want to do an all paper hand-counted
election for 2022. however the nye
county election clerk says she doesn't
have the resources to make that kind of
change the first mail ballots for the
june primary are scheduled to be sent
out in just a few weeks
next here on politics now more state
troopers saying sayonara
this is an issue that has to be
addressed right now
the eight news now i-team tells us why
people are leaving nevada state police
the problems it's causing on our roads
and what can be done
plus interest rates on the way up we're
going to break down what that means for
your wallet and for inflation
[Music]
welcome back to politics now
a question from our eight news now i
team why are nevada state police
troopers being paid less than their
counterparts well this week we showed
you that there is a lack of troopers and
it might be affecting your our safety
now overnight sometimes there are just
four nevada state police troopers on our
roads the i-team's david charns looks at
why there are so few applicants signing
up
yes we do have a problem yes yes it is
very concerning concerning because the
lack of men and women patrolling
nevada's highways could mean more danger
on the roads the very viability of our
state police is in jeopardy because of
lack of personnel those comments during
an interim meeting of a legislative
committee in december
we have shifts day shifts that have six
troopers working the valley as the eight
news now i-team reported monday nevada
state police highway patrol is having a
rough time retaining employees and
attracting new ones overall we're well
over 150
positions short
hiring has been extremely difficult
applications are few and far between
pay and retirement benefits are big
reasons why more than 20 percent of a
trooper's salary is automatically taken
out for retirement a state law requires
an employer to cover a police or fire
employee's retirement contribution but
the state of nevada is exempt data from
the state lets us compare area police
salaries a sergeant in henderson can
start at one hundred thousand dollars a
year compared to eighty one thousand for
metro and fifty five thousand for state
police in my almost 29 years law
enforcement i've never seen this before
wayne dice is with the nevada state
police union he says at least 30 union
members most of them troopers have left
the department this year that's led
tonight when just three or four are on
the road patrolling the entire las vegas
valley our state police make less than
most municipal officers in his state of
the state address last month governor
steve sisilak promised to raise state
police wages when the legislature
returns to carson city i will be
proposing a salary increase so we
guarantee that nevada state police are
well trained and well paid the board of
examiners which the governor chairs are
proving a new collective bargaining
agreement for the police union with a
two percent retroactive pay bump but
that can't start until next year at the
earliest this is an issue that has to be
addressed right now because every week
that goes by we have more people leaving
david charns live local now
records obtained by the eight news now
i-team show a total of 92 uniformed
officers for the entire las vegas valley
for 2014. that number fell to 72 last
year the union for nevada state police
officers say it's now 60. the union says
the department took troopers off of its
dui strike team to try and cover shifts
at least two troopers were pulled to
help with recruitment the job posting
right now for entry level officers at
the department of public safety shows 65
vacancies
this is affecting the lives of our
citizens people are dying it's incumbent
upon the citizens of this state to take
this seriously
governor sysolak two years ago when he
announced nevada will close for business
because of the coronavirus certainly a
lot has changed since then two years ago
it's baffling to think about how much is
different in just two years joe moller
looks at how the pandemic is still
affecting las vegas
i wear sweatpants on the bottom most of
the time sarah evans says the pandemic
changed her lifestyle when the pandemic
hit we shut it down temporarily only to
never return her business 7's pr went
remote like many others march 2020 the
strip shut down and fears of recession
like impact kicked in the tourism
industry shut down the economy as a
whole really slowed down and then we
started to see this ramp up in activity
brian gordon from applied analysis says
what didn't slow down was the real
estate market he says in 2021 more than
75 thousand people surrendered out of
state licenses people's ability to work
remotely also helped
bring folks in and allowed them to
generate additional demand in the
housing market the idea working from
home prompted many to move i get a lot
of calls out of state a lot of people
from the surrounding states real estate
agent rosetta gutierrez ue says she
still gets clients who are going to be
here working remote mainly because
the value and price during the pandemic
the city of las vegas launched a
campaign on linkedin to show people why
living in las vegas is a good option
when working remote the city had more
than 3 000 connections on linkedin due
to that campaign we have clients who are
remote decentralized so nobody has an hq
evan says it's been a success as more
companies are going remote especially
when trying to set up a meeting it's
really not a hard sell to get them to
come to vegas to meet up
and that was joe mola reporting another
impact gordon mentioned rent it's gone
up substantially during the pandemic he
doesn't see that slowing down anytime
soon
next on politics now getting our
schedules on track the reasons the
senate says it has passed a bill to get
rid of daylight saving time
plus the federal reserve announced an
interest rate hike i'm alexandra limon
in washington coming up we'll take a
look at how that will impact inflation
monday live at 11 on 8 news now
you're watching politics now
you may have noticed interest rates are
going up this week the federal reserve
made the move to try and fight inflation
in rising prices the fed increased
interest rates by a quarter of a
percentage point economic experts say
it's an effort to try and cool off the
economy
they're going to try to change the
conditions in the credit market to make
it more difficult to give credit and
more difficult to obtain credit
the federal reserve raised interest
rates wednesday by a quarter of a
percentage point the american economy is
very strong and well positioned to
handle tighter monetary policy norbert
michelle vice president of the cato
institute's center for monetary and
financial alternative says the fed is
trying to cool off the economy they're
going to try to change the conditions in
the credit market to make it more
difficult to give credit and more
difficult to obtain credit higher
interest rates and less credit should
drive demand down which in turn should
drive down inflation but there are
concerns about how higher interest rates
will impact consumers i'm worried about
the impact it has on homeowners and
mortgage
rates still nevada congresswoman susie
lee says the benefits should outweigh
the drawbacks the federal reserve will
do this in a way and keep it carefully
monitor this so it doesn't have
the an impact of further worsening the
economy the fed's change is probably
going to have very little impact on
people michelle says the fed doesn't
directly control things like mortgage
rates if you look at say mortgage rates
from a year ago they're almost a full
percentage point higher in washington
alexandra limon
reserve chair jerome powell says rate's
going to keep going up he's expecting
six more hikes before the end of the
year
next on politics now saying goodbye to
time changes the new push in congress to
get rid of daylight savings time saving
time
hurry it all ends monday
you're watching politics now
something maybe we can all agree on this
week the senate voted to do away with
daylight saving time the bill still
needs to pass the house though and get
the president's signature both nevada
senators voted to end the one-hour time
change which you just went through of
course new jersey democratic congressman
frank pallone says it is time
for a change
this is all an inconvenience but
unfortunately the changing of our clocks
has impacts on our health and our
economy
it's worth noting former president
richard nixon actually got rid of
daylight saving time back in 1974 but it
was reversed in 1975.
several deaths at that time were blamed
on children walking to school in the
dark in the winter
lawmakers are now asking how the irs is
handling tax season there's a massive
backlog of course the agency is still
processing returns from previous years
but the hope is they're going to be cut
up by the end of this year however it
can only do that by hiring thousands of
employees through 2022
if you're worried about a delayed tax
return the irs says the process is a lot
quicker if you file electronically the
sooner the better
this week in what to watch senate
hearings for katanji brown jackson she
is president joe biden's supreme court
nominee she has confirmation hearings
starting on tuesday republicans are
expected to accuse her though of being
soft on crime the white house is aiming
to secure bipartisan support for jackson
but they can still confirm her with just
a simple majority democrats are expected
to push that judge brown is actually an
ally of law enforcement we will
certainly keep tabs on that in what to
watch this week
it's going to be very busy week ahead in
politics we thank you so much for
watching us here on politics now don't
forget all the political news you need
you can stay up to date with it online
just head to 8newsnow.com we're back
with you here every saturday thank you
very much for watching we'll see you
next time